as an introduction to the main topic of
this lecture sequence let us go through
a simple example and on the way
review what we have learned so far the
example that we're going to consider
involves three tosses of a biased coin
it's a coin that results in heads with
probability P we're going to make this a
little more precise and the coin is
biased in the sense that this number P
is not necessarily the same as one-half
we represent this particular
probabilistic experiment in terms of a
tree that shows us the different stages
of the experiment each particular branch
corresponds to a sequence of possible
results in the different stages and the
leaves of this tree correspond to the
possible outcomes the branches of this
tree are annotated by certain numbers
and these numbers are to be interpreted
appropriately as probabilities or
conditional probabilities so for example
this number here is interpreted as the
probability of heads in the first toss
an event that we denote as h1 this
number here is to be interpreted as a
conditional probability
it's the conditional probability of
obtaining heads in the second toss given
that the first toss resulted in hands
and finally this number here is to be
interpreted as the conditional
probability of heads in the third toss
given that the first toss resulted in
heads and the second toss also resulted
in heads let us now continue with some
calculations first we're going to
practice the multiplication rule which
is which allows us to calculate the
probability of a certain outcome in this
case the outcome of interest is tails
followed by heads followed by tails so
we're talking about this particular
outcome here according to the
multiplication rule to find the
probability of a particular final
outcome we multiply probabilities and
conditional probabilities along the path
that lead
to this particular outcome so in this
case it's 1 minus P times P times 1
minus P let us now calculate the
probability of a certain event the event
of interest is the event that we obtain
exactly one head in the three tosses
this is an event that can happen in
multiple ways here's one possibility
where we have a single head
here's another possibility and here's a
third one these are the three possible
ways that we have a can have exactly one
hand depending on who are exactly that
single hand appears is it in the first
toss in the second or in the third to
find the total probability of this event
we need to add the probability of the
different outcomes that corresponds to
this event the probability of this
outcome is P times 1 minus P squared the
probability of this outcome is what we
calculated it's again P times 1 minus P
squared and the probability of the third
one is also P times 1 minus P squared so
the answer is 3 P times 1 minus P
squared notice that each one of the
three different ways that this event can
happen have the same probability so
these three outcomes are equally likely
finally let us calculate a conditional
probability and this is essentially the
Bayes rule suppose that we were told
that there was exactly one hand so in
particular the blue event has occurred
and we're interested in the probability
that the first toss is heads which
corresponds to this event here these are
all the outcomes in which the first toss
is equal to hands so given that the blue
event happened what is the probability
that the green event happens you can
guess the answer that it should be one
third why is that each one of these blue
outcomes has the same probability so
when you condition on the blue outcome
having
happened the conditional probability of
each one of these should be one-third so
even that the blue outcome happened
there's probability one-third that this
particular one has happened and this is
the only one that makes the green event
happen but let us see if we can derive
this answer in a formal manner let's see
if we're going to get one-third we use
the definition of conditional
probabilities the conditional
probability is the ratio first of the
probability that both events happen
divided by the probability of the
conditioning event which is the
probability of one hand now the
probability of both events happening
that we have exactly one hand and the
first toss is heads this is the
intersection of the blue event and the
green event which can happen only in
this particular outcome namely the
sequence heads tails tails and has
probability P times 1 minus P squared
the denominator is something that we
have already calculated it's 3 P times 1
minus P squared and so the final answer
is 1/3 as we have guessed let me now
make a few comments about this
particular example this particular
example is pretty special
in the following respect we have that
the probability of h2 heads in the
second toss given that the first one was
heads is equal to P and the same is true
for the conditional probability of heads
in the second toss given that the first
one was tails in other words our beliefs
about what may happen in the second toss
remains the same there's a probability P
of obtaining
heads no matter what happens in the
first toss telling you the result of the
first toss doesn't change your
leaves about what may happen and with
what probability in the second stores
and if you were to calculate the
unconditional probability of heads in
the second toss what you would get using
the total probability theorem would be
the following it's probability of heads
in the first toss times probability of
heads in the second given heads in the
first plus the probability of tails in
the first toss times the probability of
heads in the second toss given tails in
the first and if you do the algebra this
turns out to be equal to P again so the
unconditional probability of heads in
the second toss turns out to be the same
as the conditional probabilities again
knowing what happened in the first toss
doesn't change your beliefs about the
second toss which were associated with
this particular probability P so what
we're going to do next is to generalize
this special situation by giving a
definition of Independence of events and
then discuss various properties and
concepts associated with Independence